and I go Jerry what's your message to
that guy this guy's being infected by
the economic crushing from kova just
like everybody else what's your message
don't you have a message to recruit him
because if you don't have a message the
Nazis are going to have a message we got
to have a message and he goes I don't
have a message for that guy and I'm like
well that's why nobody ever heard of you
and that's why you've never accomplished
anything in your life because that's not
how you organize you know how you
organize just like Christian Smalls did
at the Amazon warehouse on Staten Island
now if you don't know of Staten Island
it's all full of trump voters and he's a
black guy who organized a union of trump
voters on Staten Island and how do you
do that well I'll tell you how you don't
do it you don't go to the Union Florida
who cares a proud boy you're out who's a
Boogaloo boy you're out who doesn't like
Social Security you're out who's against
lgbtq you're out who's who's a
Libertarian gun nut you're out okay
who's left now let's organize that's not
how you do it everybody knows that's not
how you organize